madame monsieur bonsoir les
organisations humanitaires tentent de
faire face au rwanda mais l'ampleur du
drame est telle que les responsables qui
travaillent sur le terrain reconnaissent
leur impuissance à la barbarie de la
guerre il faut ajouter maintenant le
choléra depuis hier une épidémie
foudroyante a déjà fait des milliers de
morts à chaque minute qui passe un
réfugié moeurs disait un médecin à goma
cet après midi reportage à la frontière
entre le zaïre et le rwanda de patricia
cost et philippe chaska le choléra
l'épidémie a explosé aujourd'hui dans
les camps des réfugiés rwandais des
centaines de morts ont été amenés ici à
proximité des tempes de médecins sans
frontières
diarrhées vomissements il confirme
choléra la majorité des assistances au
zaïre waro mais il y a que deux médecins
de msf et trois infirmières désespérée
on est immergé qu'il ya encore trop de
cas il ya beaucoup trop de monde qui a
pu encore ya déjà sur le chemin quand on
est venu ce matin il ya 800 ans tort
qu'on a découvert comme ça sur le bord
de la route quand on est arrivé il y
avait encore une centaine de corps on
repasse pour l'instant vous reprendre
encore tous les corps qui sont décédés
il y en a encore une centaine et que de
toute façon réhydrater les gens avec le
personnel qu'on ne connaît pas qu'on a
engagés comme ça avec 2,3 expats vous
mettez le passé complètement expatriés
vous êtes combien de médecins on est
pour l'instant on est trois médecins ici
deux médecins devant l'ampleur tout à
fait qu'on soit là ou pas là je crois
que l'impact de il est très faible mais
vous arrivez quand même à sauver
certaines personnes sauvées j'espère
quand même mais
passons devant revenir laonnois c'est le
début en fait cela c'est le début le
début d'épidémie
ouais c'est le début ça va mal et de la
très vite ça va très vite l'accusation
pour le choléra ces deux trois jours
l'immunité très faible et de toute façon
combien toute façon pas maintenant de
suppléments d'eau potable correct pour
l'instant il continue à prendre de l'eau
là qui vont ils continuer à prendre de
l'eau sur le chemin et toute cette eau
est souillée donc de toutes façons ça ne
change absolument rien les perfusion de
glucose c'est un des membres de la
famille du malade qui les appliquent
faute de personnel travail mal fait
insuffisant il faudrait plusieurs
sachets de suite ils ne le savent pas
forcément personne de vie sur terre le
soigner il dort où quelques jeunes
traités il pourrait ressusciter aussi
vite
il arrive près de ce centre un des rares
en place par autobus entier de tous les
environs et les zaïrois sont aussi
touchés c'est le cas par an mais
vraiment jamais la balle aux plages le
problème de l'évacuation des cadavres
restent entiers run de camions
d'équipements pour protéger les
bénévoles qui accuse la grande et plus
chance d'y échapper d'ilha grande deux
petits saint sauveur ce qu'ils en font
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait